i've just been
doing a lot of work and
i guess i'm pretty confident saying like
four years you know james franco is
speaking out the natural human instinct
is to
just make it stop the 43 year old actor
is breaking his silence on the sexual
misconduct lawsuit against him and
taking an extended break from hollywood
in his first interview in nearly four
years with sirius xm's jess cagle
did not seem like the right time to say
anything
there were people that were upset with
me and
i needed to listen franco addresses the
2018 sexual misconduct allegations made
against him by multiple women and also
speaks on the 2019 lawsuit filed against
his acting school well in 2018
there were some complaints about me and
an article about me and
at that moment
i just thought
i'm going to be quiet i'm going to be
i'm going to pause et confirmed in
february of 2021 that franco reached a
settlement in the 2019 lawsuit by his
former acting students agreeing to 2
million 235
thousand dollars
the suit was filed by two women who
accused franco of creating an
environment of harassment and sexual
exploitation with one of them claiming
there was an abuse of power and culture
of exploiting non-celebrity women look
i'll admit
i did sleep with
students over the course of my teaching
i did sleep with students and that was
wrong
there were certain instances where
you know what
i was in a consensual thing with with a
student and i shouldn't have been the
actor opens up in the interview about
his past substance addiction and how
it's changed his perspective there were
some issues that i had to deal with that
were also related to addiction and so
i've i've really used my my recovery
background to kind of
start examining this and changing
who i was i suppose
at the time
my thinking was
if it's consensual
okay i guess it just comes down to my
criteria was like if this is consensual
like i think it's cool we're all adults
so
franco also reveals that he's been in
recovery for sex addiction since 2016
and even acknowledges cheating on all of
his past partners prior to his current
girlfriend isabella paxsad
i could never be faithful to anybody so
i cheated i cheated on everyone
before isabel even my sponsor was like
you know who's happily married he's like
look the cheating
is dishonest i don't think that's good
for your sobriety but
if you're not dating someone and
you want to go and hook up like whatever
happens between two consenting adults is
fine like that's what he said the
problem was
i took that
and i ran with it he even goes on to
admit he was completely blind to power
dynamics and to people's feelings the
behavior spun out to a point where it
was
like i was hurting everybody
aside from all the self-reflection
franco reveals that being out of the
spotlight for four years has had one
major positive aspect
i have changed it's given me the
incentive to to do the work to change
i've got it i'm you know i'll i'll keep
working at it for the rest of my life
james addresses how his new outlook has
also influenced a change in his tendency
to be a workaholic it got me off that
path that was never going to end and
would probably kill me i think i truly
believe like if i kept going with my
work addiction
i probably would have relapsed on
alcohol since these allegations came to
light franco's longtime friend and
frequent collaborator seth rogen made
comments back in may that he no longer
plans to work with him i love south
rogan i worked with him for 20 years he
was my
absolute closest work friend
collaborator we aren't working together
right now and we don't have any plans to
work together of course it was hurtful
you know in context but i get it
as for why franco decided to speak out
now well rogan was a big part in that
decision you know he had to answer for
me because i was silent he had to answer
for me and
i don't want that it's one of the main
reasons i wanted to talk to you today is
i just i don't want
seth or my brother or anyone to have to
answer for me anymore